how you doing guys today we have a
2023 Dodge Ram 1500 and we need to make
extra key let's get
started by the way if you like those
videos make sure to like And subscribe
so you can see our daily videos so the
customer have original and we're going
to create otel Universal key that I
prepared with the km 100 so first I'm
going to turn the ignition on by
pressing twice on the start button and
all the dash lights are going to come on
and we're going to go to the uh IM 100
or im508 I'm going to go to immobilizer
and we're going to go to American
Vehicles we're going to go to
[Music]
dodge I'm going to go to manual
selection and I'm going to go to North
America and and we're going to slide
down I slided to a Ram 1500 but you need
1500 DT I'm going to hit smart key 2018
and up I'm going to hit yes if you have
learn key turn ignition on ignition is
already
on so uh we're going to hit
okay it tells me that I need to use the
cable the special cable I have a video
that shows how to use the star connector
and it tells us that we should choose
Ram 1500 DT I'm already here in the menu
so I'm going to read the PIN code but
the programming I'm going to go back and
do it through the DT we're going to go
to control unit I'm going to go to
immobilizer password tells me to turn
the ignition off and turn the hazard
lights on we're going to do it and then
we're going to hit
[Music]
okay
that's going to take between 1 minute
and 10 minutes to read the PIN code I'm
going to fast
[Music]
forward
we should get five
digit yep there is the PIN code we're
going to keep uh memorizing the PIN code
I'm going to go back to the menu and I'm
going to slide one again and I'm going
to go to DT 19 and 22 23 is the same I'm
going to hit
yes insert learn key and turn the
ignition on ignition is already on going
to hit
okay tells me I need to use the star
connector TI cable we already using it
going to go to control unit we're going
to go to kila system because we already
have the
password so we're going to go kiler
system we're going to go to key learning
we're going to go to number of keys just
to verify how many keys are in the
memory we have two
keys we're going to do key
learning and please remove all the
proximity Keys the existing one so I'm
going to take the other one away and
we're just going to keep the new one in
the car and we're going to hit
okay so it tells me if I want to
register the new key now those keys you
need to hold it like I'm holding it uh
in this angle and be prepared whenever
it tells you to push on it so he ask me
for the PIN code I'm going to hit okay
and when he tells me I'm going to push
and hold it pushed I'm going to push the
start
button you'll have to push it until it
finish the entire counting usually it
finish like half of it about 30 seconds
and then it's going to register just
like
that Please Release the start button so
I'm going to remove the push start I'm
going to hit
okay learning successful you want the
next key no we don't I'm going to test
the key right
[Music]
now and everything work the way it
should thank you very much for watching
if you have any questions let me know in
the comments
below and thank you again for watching
and please don't forget to like And
subscribe so you can see all of our
daily lockmith videos thank you
[Music]
again